THIS BUDGET FISCAL REVIEW
SUBCOMMITTEE TO WILL COME TO
ORDER GOOD MORNING AND ESIC AS
WE CONTINUE TO TAKE SOME
PRECAUTIONS TO MANAGE ONGOING
COVERT NINETEEN REDUCE THE
SENATE CONTINUES TO WELCOME THE
PUBLIC AND HAS PROVIDED ACCESS
TO BOTH IN PERSON AND
TELECONFERENCE PARTICIPATION FOR
THE PUBLIC FOR INDIVIDUALS.
WISHING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT VIA THE TELECONFERENCE
OR FIRST THE PARTICIPATION TOLL
FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE IS
POSTED ON A COMMITTEE WEBSITE IT
WILL BE DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN
THROUGHOUT THESE PROCEEDINGS AND
I WILL NOW SIT NOW THESE
PARTICIPATION NUMBER IS EIGHT
FOUR FOUR. TWO NINE ONE SIX
THREE SIX FOUR IN THE ACCESS
CODE IS FOUR ONE. ONE FOUR ONE
ONE ONE FOUR- LET ME SAY THAT
AGAIN ONE FOUR ONE ONE ONE FOUR-
AND- IS THERE- AND ADDITIONALLY
YOU CAN ALSO SEND YOUR COMMENTS
WRITTEN COMMENTS IN TO- THE
SENATE BUDGET COMMITTEE AND-
ALSO ACCESS TO OUR WEBSITE WE
WILL ADD THOSE TO THE RECORD I
WILL MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING A
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY. AND IS
INDIVIDUALS WHO. ANY IN THE
WHOSE DISRUPTED MAY BE REMOVED
FROM THE REMOTE START MEETING
SERVICE OR HAVE THE CONNECTION
MUTED WE ARE HOLDING OUR
COMMITTEE HEARINGS HERE IN THE-
STREET BUILDING HI WE DO HAVE AS
SUFFICIENT MEMBERS HERE. IN ROOM
TWELVE HUNDRED TO ESTABLISH A
QUORUM WILL DO THAT SHORTLY-
BEFORE WE BEGIN THOSE PROVIDING
TESTIMONY BEFORE THE COMMITTEE
TODAY. ARE ALSO- PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY FOR A REMOTE
PARTICIPANTS PLEASE MUTE YOUR
PHONES OR COMPUTERS THIS WILL
GREATLY AID ELIMINATING ANY
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK I S. IT EVERY
TIME YOU WISH TO BE RECOGNIZED
THAT UC RAISE THE HAND FEATURE
IN YOUR PROGRAM. EACH TIME
YOU'LL BE RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK A
POP UP WINDOW WILL APPEAR
ASKING. IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO.
PLEASE SELECT ON MUTE BEFORE YOU
BEGIN SPEAKING OUR IT STAFF WILL
PUT YOU BACK ON MUTE WHEN YOU'RE
DONE ONCE RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK
PLEASE MAKE SURE THAT YOU CAN BE
SEEN ON THE SCREEN SAY YOUR NAME
AND THEN WE'RE READY TO TRADE.
YOU'LL BE READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WILL BE WE HAVE ADMITTED
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC INTO THE
HEARING ROOM. HERE AT- TWELVE
HUNDRED- ST. THAT TO THE EXTENT
THAT THE- SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOWED IT WILL.
AND WE WILL BE USING THE
TELECONFERENCE RVERS FOR
INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
TODAY PUBLIC COMMENT WILL BE
HEARD. AFTER ALL OUR DISCUSSION
ITEMS HAVE BEEN PRESENTED-
LET'S. BEGIN BY ESTABLISHING A
QUORUM MISS RORY WILL YOU
PLEASE. CALL THE ROLL. WHAT
KASKY HERE CASKEY SAID DOLLY
YOUR DAILY HERE REQUIRE. MCGUIRE
STERN HERE'S STERN HERE. WOULD
YOU LIKE TO ANNOUNCED THE HE
ATTENDED. WE HAVE EVERYONE HERE
OKAY WE HAVE FOUR FULL
MEMBERSHIP- THIRD TWENTY NINE
MEMBERS ON- A TWENTY NINE ISSUES
ON THE- VOTE ONLY CALENDAR LET'S
START OFF WITH ISSUE NUMBER
THIRTY THIS IS A NEW BUDGET
CONTROL SECTION TWENTY POINT- OH
THREE APPROPRIATIONS AND- RE
VERSIONS I DO WE WILL HAVE A
PRESENTATION BY BY FINANCING
THEM NATURALLY I'LL GO TO MY
FRIENDS FDLE- SO MR OCULAR
MISTER HALL. THE FLOOR IS YOURS
THIS IS ISSUE NUMBER. THIRTY
GOOD MORNING SURE MEMBERS THIS
IS AMBER ALL WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE I AM I'M HERE TO
PRESENT A PROPOSAL THAT'S REALLY
INTENDED TO STREAMLINE SOME OF
THE TECHNICAL WORK LOAD THAT.
DEPARTMENTS FINANCE THE
LEGISLATURE HAVE TO CONSIDER
EACH YEAR THROUGH THE ANNUAL
BUDGET PROCESS. I'LL GIVE A
REALLY BRIEF OVER VIEW AND I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THAT MEMBERS MAY HAVE. I'M
CONTROL SECTION TWENTY A FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION TODAY. IT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE'VE DEVELOPED
TO FOCUS ON A LIMITED SCOPE OF
LANGUAGE ONLY ITEMS TYPICALLY RE
APPROPRIATIONS AND REPARATIONS.
TIME FOR SPECIFIED BONDED NON
GOVERNMENTAL COSTS FUNDS. SO AS
YOU KNOW EACH YEAR THE
ADMINISTRATION INCLUDES BOND
TECHNICAL PROPOSALS. AND AS A
COMPONENT OF THOSE WE INCLUDE
AND EXTENSIONS OF LIQUIDATION
AND REPRESENTS THIS LANGUAGES
TECHNICAL IN NATURE- BUT IT ALSO
REQUIRES A REALLY GRANULAR LEVEL
OF DETAIL. IN ORDER TO GET THAT
INCLUDED INTO THE BUDGET ACT
EACH YEAR- IN SOME CASES WE FIND
TYPOS OR SOME SORT OF CLERICAL
ERROR WHERE. WE SUBSEQUENTLY
AFTER COME BACK WITH ANOTHER
SPRING FINANCE LETTER. AND THEN
MAKE I AM AMENDMENTS TO THE
EXISTING BUDGET BILLS IN ORDER
TO FIX THOSE. AND SO WE HAVE
BEEN LOOKING AT WAYS THAT WE CAN
ALLEVIATE YOU KNOW SOME OF THIS
TECHNICAL WORKLOAD FOR EVERYBODY
INVOLVED. AND THOUGHT THAT THIS
WAS AN AREA WHERE WE CAN
STREAMLINE THE PROCESS. I AM.
AND STILL PROVIDE LEGISLATIVE
OVERSIGHT THROUGH THE JAIL B. C.
NOTIFICATION PROCESS. HI I AM
I'D SAY THE GOAL HERE REALLY IS
TO JUST DE COUPLE SOME OF THESE
LANGUAGE ONLY ITEMS FROM THE
BUDGET BILL THEMSELVES. AND
INSTEAD I AM CONSOLIDATE THESE
ALL INTO ONE SPREADSHEET. THE
JAIL BC COULD RUBIO AND IT WOULD
ALSO PLACE THIS CRIME INTO ONE
SPREADSHEET FOR SCO TO UPDATE ON
THEIR RECORDS- RATHER THAN
HAVING THE SORT OF LISTED
THROUGHOUT THE BUDGET BILLS EACH
YEAR AS WE DO CURRENTLY. AND TO
BE CLEAR. WE WOULD STILL GO
THROUGH THE TRADITIONAL BCP
PROCESS FOR ANYTHING THAT
REQUIRED A NEW APPROPRIATION. OR
ANY INCREASES OR DECREASES TO-
EXISTING DEPARTMENT
APPROPRIATIONS AND THE BUDGET
BILLS. AS WELL AS ANYTHING THAT
INCLUDED I AM NEW POSITION
REQUESTS. AND SO WE'RE REALLY
VIEWING MESSES IS. TRYING TO
SHIFT SOME OF THE REALLY
TECHNICAL LANGUAGE ITEMS UNDER A
NEW PROCESS THAT WOULD HOPEFULLY
SAVE TIME FOR EVERYBODY. I'M
WITH THAT I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS THAT. ANYBODY
MIGHT HAVE. MISS KRISTEN-
WEYRICH SICK WITH THE L. L. I.
K. I SEE THAT THE PRESENTATION
FROM FINANCES THEY'RE NOT
TALKING ABOUT THE- MONEY PORTION
OF A BOND FUNDED PROJECTS OR- A
LEASE REVENUE FUNDED PROJECT I
THINK THEY'RE JUST LOOKING AT
THE LANGUAGE THE TECHNICAL
LANGUAGE. BUT I'D BE INTERESTED
IN IN IN. WITH EVERYBODY'S
INTERESTED IN YOUR INPUT SO GOOD
MORNING AND THAT. THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. I THINK HE'S SO MUCH
CHEERING AND SENATORS MY NAME IS
HELEN KIRSTY WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE SO
YEAH I TO CLARIFY THIS LANGUAGE
BUT A FIVE FOR AND THINGS LIKE
WE APPROPRIATIONS AND WERE
VIRGINS OF THIS IS THIS IS- YOU.
TYPICALLY FOR EXAMPLE- BONTA AND
HAVE A CERTAIN AMOUNT OF TIME
AND OVER WHICH YOU HAVE TO SPEND
THEM AND EITHER WAY THEY NEED TO
BE RE APPROPRIATED AND- AND FOR
EXAMPLE THIS WOULD BASICALLY
ALLOW THE ADMINISTRATION TO AND
PHYSICALLY ADMINISTRATIVELY-
EXTENDS THOSE THROUGH IT YOU
KNOW PROVIDING THE LEGISLATURE
WIT THE NOTIFICATION. RATHER
THAN COMING BACK WITH A BUDGET
CHANGE PROPOSAL CURRENTLY- FOR
GENERAL OBLIGATION BONDS- FOR
EXAMPLE THERE'S OFTEN A
CONSOLIDATED- TECHNICAL A
PROPOSAL AND THAT PROVIDES ALL
OF THOSE AND YOU SERVE A LIST OF
ALL THE THINGS WE CONSIDERED AS
PART OF A BUDGET TEAM PROPOSAL.
AND THEN FOR THESE REVENUE BONDS
TYPICALLY THERE ARE YOU KNOW
INDIVIDUAL PROPOSALS THAT ARE
THAT ARE PUT. FORWARD TO THE
LEGISLATURE SO. WE NOW THEY'RE
SEEN AS THE PEASY AND THEN
THERE'S LANGUAGE INCLUDE IN. BY
BILL AND SO I THINK EVEN. HAS
BEEN- THE THAT DOES TAKE THE-
TIME FOR THEM TO COMPILE. TIME
AND THEN THERE'S NOT A LOT OF
TECHNICAL WORK ON ON THEIR END.
WE THINK CERTAINLY THAT THE
CONCEPT OF STREAMLINING THAT
PROCESS AND NOT WORK AND YOU
KNOW HAS MAKES A LOT OF SENSE
AND THERE IS WE DO RECOGNIZE
THERE IS. SUBSTANTIAL WORK ON
THE PART OF THE ADMINISTRATION
AND IN DOING THAT I'M AND THAT
IN SOME CASES THESE REALLY ARE
JUST TECHNICAL NON CONTROVERSIAL
REVERBERATIONS EXTENSION
BASICALLY OF ONE OF SPENDING.
FORTY OR AUTHORIZATIONS RIVER
FRIENDS I'M SPEAKING IN GENERAL
THAT'S REASONABLE HOWEVER WE DO
RECOGNIZE THAT- THE JOINT
LEGISLATIVE BUDGET COMMITTEE
PROCESS- ISN'T PERHAPS THE MOST
AND- THE MOST WELL SUITED TO
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT AND IT'S
NOT. SOMETHING THAT'S VERY
PUBLIC PROCESS AND IT'S NOT
SOMETHING THAT- FIGHT IS EASY
FOR FOLKS TO AND MISTER SEA
WHAT'S GOING ON AND SERVE
OVERSEAS SO WE DO THINK IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT AND- TO ONLY
USE IT FOR THOSE TECHNICAL. AND
NON CONTROVERSIAL ITEMS AND
REALLY MAKE SURE THAT
LEGISLATORS COMFORTABLE WITH
WITH THIS EXPANSION- AND ALSO TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE LEGISLATURE
HAS ENOUGH TIME AND INFORMATION.
TO REALLY FACILITATE ITS REVIEWS
SO WE HAVE A FEW SUGGESTIONS-
BUT THE LEGISLATURE CONSIDER
FROM MODIFYING THE LANGUAGE I
HAVE. TO TAKE INTO ACCOUNT THOSE
CONSIDERATIONS. THE FIRST THING
IS THE LEGISLATURE READ SHOULD.
WHETHER IT COMFORTABLE. HAVING
THIS LIKE A FIVE TO OF THE REFER
. AND REVERSION ON FOR. GENERAL
THE BONDS IN AND THESE ARE ABOUT
THE THAT THE NAME. THIS IS FOR
HER- TO AND I ACTUALLY NOT OF
YOUR MIND AND MANY. ANYWHERE DID
YOU BUY AND ALL THESE REVENUE.
AND THAT'S WHAT'S CURRENTLY FROM
TO YOU- SO WE WORK LET'S JUST
CAN WHETHER COME WITH APPROACH.
OR WOULD LIKE TO WOMEN FOR A- WE
KNOW THEY'RE BEING. STATE KINDS
RELATED TO PRISON CRISIS- IN A
PATH- AND- THERE'S A LOT OF
ACTIVITY IT RICH REGARD TO
PRISONS- AND THE POTENTIAL
CLOSURE PRESENTS SO THAT'S BEEN
AN AREA WHERE FOR EXAMPLE THE
LEGISLATURE. HAS HAS- HE HAD A
PARTICULAR INTEREST IN TO. IN
ADDITIONAL. OF THAT'S THE CASE
ON THE CASE OF PROJECTS BE X.
FROM. PROCESS IF WORKS AN THE
WISH OF THE LEISURE. UNDER OTHER
WAY FOR VERY LARGE- FINE
APPROPRIATIONS COULD BE EXCLUDED
. OR AN YOU KNOW. THAT HAVE
RECEIVED. REPORTS THERE AT COULD
BE TO THEIR- DAY OPTIONS THERE
BUT WE DO WANNA MAKE SURE.
LEGISLATURES REALLY- HAVE
THOUGHT ABOUT WHAT IT RIGHT OR
ARE WHETHER THERE'S CASES. THAT
IT'S NOT WITH. THE SECOND-
RECOMMENDATION WE HAVE IS THAT
THE LEGISLATURE. THE TINY AND
WHETHER WANTS TO PROVIDE ANY
LIMIT TO ON MANY NOTICES INCOME
FOR. SO ONE OF THE ISSUES THAT
SOME HAPPEN IS. ON THE
LEGISLATURE BOTH MEMBERS AND
STAFF AND GET A LIFE GET
REQUESTS RIGHT AT THE END OF THE
BUDGET PROCESS. AND THINGS ARE
SO BUSY THAT IT'S REALLY
DIFFICULT AND WITH THE OTHER
COMPETING WORK LED TO DO THAT
DUE DILIGENCE THAT WOULD BE
IDEAL. ON SOME OF THESE THINGS
AND SO ONE THING AND THAT THE
LEGISLATURE COULD CONSIDER IS
WHETHER IT WANTS TO REQUIRE THAT
THESE. NOTIFICATIONS COME
FORWARD BEFORE MAY FIRST AND
THAT WOULD ENSURE THAT THE
LEGISLATURE HAVE A LITTLE BIT A
LITTLE BIT OF TIME BEFORE THE IN
THE BUDGET PROCESS TO REVIEW
THEM. AND FINALLY- WORK IN THE
LEGISLATURE CONSIDER WHETHER IT
WANTS TO REQUIRE AS PART OF THE
LANGUAGE- ANY SPECIFIC
INFORMATION BE REQUIRED SO WE-
WE CERTAINLY RECOGNIZE THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION AND- HAS IT HAS
EXPRESSED ITS INTENT TO PROVIDE
DETAILED INFORMATION IN A
SPREADSHEET ON THE THREE
CORPORATIONS MAKING THAT'S
REALLY VALUABLE. BUT WE THINK
THAT IT WOULD BE WORTHWHILE TO
MEMORIALIZE THAT IN AND IN
LANGUAGE- AS PART OF THE CONTROL
SECTION THAT WAY YOU KNOW AS-
AND- TIME MOVES FORWARD
DIFFERENT PEOPLE ARE IN
POSITIONS- YOU KNOW THINGS
CHANGE- WELL I'LL BE CLEAR. ON
WHAT'S EXPECTED AS PART OF THESE
NOTIFICATIONS TO ENSURE THAT THE
LEGISLATURE REALLY GET THE
INFORMATION THAT IT NEEDS TO
MAKE. MAKE SURE YOU THOSE-
REQUESTING THAT THEY REALLY
BEGAN OUR TECHNICAL- AND. AND
ARE NOT CONTROVERSIAL. I'M HAPPY
TO TAKE ANY PART. FORGET THIS
MISTER HALL MISS US YEAR TROW.
GREEN HE GOT JOINT BUDGETCOMMITTEE. RATHER THAN THIS
COMMITTEE SO WE- WITH SORT OF A
DEGREE. WHAT THE EXTENSIONS. ON
WOULD BE- AS- BEEN IN THIS IDEA
THE MAIN. I CAN AND- IF KNOW THE
TECH LANGUAGE IS OFF SOMETIMES I
DON'T KNOW ON THE MONEY IF YOU
GET A NEED TO REVERSE AND THEY
THEY'RE IT'S SORT OF CLOSE. AT I
RECALL AS WE DO THIS EVERY YEAR
WE GET TO. JUNE AND THEY THEY'RE
NOT GONNA BE ABLE CLOSE OUT THE
BIGGEST THING ONE EXTENSION.
JUST AS THE FINISH UP STUFF. YOU
GUYS HAVE A COMMENT ON THE
ALEJO'S- SUGGESTED
RECOMMENDATIONS. ONCE YOU. WE
CERTAINLY WANT TO BE. WE
CERTAINLY WANT TO BE WITH THIS
PROCESS I'M AND YOU KNOW THE
INTENT IS TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE PROVIDING A SUFFICIENT
LEVEL OF- INFORMATION AND SO. TO
BE CLEAR RIGHT NOW WE START WITH
A VERY BROAD AND DETAILED BOND
SPREAD SHEET WHERE WE WORK WITH
OUR BOND COORDINATORS AND
DEPARTMENTS EACH YEAR. AND
THAT'S SORT OF THE INFORMATION
THAT WE HAVE ALREADY
CONSOLIDATED DOWN. IT'S USUALLY
INCLUDED AS BACK UP UPON YOUR
REQUEST I AM FOR THESE ISSUES.
AND SO UNDER THIS PROCESS WE
WOULD BASICALLY TAKE THAT EXACT
SAME LEVEL OF INFORMATION.
ACTUALLY I THINK IN THIS CASE IT
MIGHT EVEN BE A LITTLE BIT MORE
BECAUSE WE'RE LOOKING AT ADDING
A FEW I AM COLUMNS THAT WOULD
THAT WOULD GIVE YOU ESTIMATED RE
APPROPRIATIONS. I'M AND THAT
WOULD JUST GO THROUGH A
DIFFERENT PROCESS SO. WE
CERTAINLY DON'T WANT THERE TO BE
A PERCEPTION THAT WORD PROVIDING
LESS INFORMATION OR THAT WE'RE
BEING LESS TRANSPARENT BECAUSE
THAT'S NOT WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
DO IT ALL. I'M AND- YOUR POINT
YES THAT SOME OF THE FLEXIBILITY
AS HELPFUL THAT. REALLY AS WE
GET NEARER TOWARDS THE END OF
SOME OF THESE OLDER BONDS I AM
THE AMOUNT AVAILABLE YOU KNOW.
BECOMES A SMALL ENOUGH AMOUNT
WHERE SOMETHING- AS SIMPLE AS
EMPLOYEE COMPOUND RETIREMENT
ADJUSTMENTS THAT HIT IN THE
CURRENT YEAR. CAN ACTUALLY
SQUEEZE SOME OF YOUR OUTER YEARS
TO THE POINT WHERE WE MIGHT NEED
TO REVERT UP TO NINE THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN ORDER TO MAKE SURE
THAT YOU KNOW A CERTAIN PART OF
THAT WAS NOT. OVER ALLOCATED.
AND SO WE REALLY DO LOVE AT THE
IS A SOME OF. THEM SOME OF THE
MOST TECHNICAL ISSUES ON THEIR-
I DON'T THINK WE REALLY HAVE
CONCERNS ABOUT. THE TIMING
NECESSARILY I THINK IT'S IN OUR
INTEREST AS WELL TOO I AM. TO
GET THESE AND YOU KNOW FOR GLBT
RUBIO AND ALSO TO GET THEM AND-
FOR SCO TO UPDATES- THE HEAD OF
THE NEXT BUDGET CYCLE- MY
UNDERSTANDING IS A LOT OF TIMES
. THESE ISSUES SORT OF GET.
EXTENDED REVERTED AFTER THAT
LAST YEAR WAS DONE. SETTING UP
SOME OF THE NEW ITEMS OF
APPROPRIATION AND SO WE'RE
ACTUALLY HOPING THAT. IF WE CAN
GET THESE THROUGH A LITTLE BIT
EARLIER THAT MIGHT ACTUALLY-
ALLEVIATE THAT ISSUE AS WELL.
MAKES SENSE- MAKE SURE YOU ANY
ADDITIONAL NOTES YOU HAVE SHARE
WITH US. THAT THE SUBCOMMITTEE
MEMBERS ANY QUESTIONS HERE IN.
ISSUE NUMBER. THIRTY WITH THE
NEW BUDGET CONTROL SECTION.
TWENTY POINT HELLO. PART STEP-
CENTER DOLLY I JUST WANNA GO ON
RECORD SAYING THAT- I'M NOT
OPPOSED TO DOING YOUR TECHNICAL
. LOW BUDGET IT HAS AS THE
ADMINISTRATION POINTED OUT TEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS OR NINE
THOUSAND BUT WORK TOWARDS THIS
IS A THIS IS A BIG POLICY.
CHANGE AND THIS IS THIS COULD
YOU I THINK I WANNA MAKE SURE
THAT. THE I. ONE OF THE- MEMBERS
TO KNOW I'M NOT IN FAVOR OF
ALLOWING JUST A CAR BLANK THERE
IS REALLY NO. LEGISLATIVE
OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO COME
TOGETHER IT'S THE BIG THREE THAT
DECIDE THESE THINGS MISTER
SPEAKER THE PROTEGER A MINUTE
MINISTRATION AND THAT'S PRETTY
MUCH WHAT HAPPENED SO I WHEN I
WAS GOING ON RECORD SAYING THE
DAILY- BRINGS UP SOME. CONCERNS
THAT WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE DOING OUR JOB AND WE'RE
MAKING SURE THAT THESE BONDS-
ARE JUST SHIFTED AROUND AND SO.
IT'S GOING ON RECORD SAYING THAT
LOOK AT US WE SHOULD SET A
DOLLAR AMOUNT. AND THEN MAYBE
MOVE FORWARD BUT NOT JUST
GIVING- MORE POWER TO THE
ADMINISTRATION TO JUST MOVE
THESE BONDS AROUND HOWEVER THEY
WANT. OKAY SEE THE- THE
QUESTIONS WERE THIS WITH THIS
MATTER WILL BE. HOLD OPEN AS WE
GO THROUGH BUDGET DISCUSSIONS
AND APPRECIATE THEIR INPUT LET'S
MOVE TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
FORESTRY AND FIRE PROTECTION-
THIS IS ISSUE NUMBER THIRTY ONE
IT'S THE OFFICE OF THE STATE
FIRE MARSHAL FIRE AND LIFE.
SAFETY DESIGNATED CAMPUS FIRE
MARSHAL PROGRAM AND THIS WE HAVE
WITH US FROM CAL FIRE- WINDY
COLLINS TO SEE ASSISTANT STATE
FIRE MARSHAL- THIS IS YOUR
PROPOSAL FOR THREE POINT TWO
MILLION REIMBURSEMENT AUTHORITY.
TO INCREASE IT- TWO POINT EIGHT
OR TO GO TO TWO POINT EIGHT AND
TWELVE POSITIONS I'M GOING WITH
THE OFFICE THE FIRE MARSHAL
WELCOME GOOD MORNING. MORNING
THANK YOU SOME TERRY AND
COMMITTEE- AGAIN MY NAME IS
WENDY COLLINS ON THE ASSISTANT
STATE FIRE MARSHAL AND I'M HAPPY
TO BE HERE THIS MORNING TO HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO. EXPRESS ANY
CLARIFICATION TO OUR NEEDS OUR
CLASS TO ADD THOSE TWELVE
ADDITIONAL COUNTERPARTS ABOUT.
TO THE FIRE AND LIFE SAFETY
DIVISION THIS WOULD SUPPORT THE
OVERSIGHT OF AN EXISTING MO YOU
WITH THE INDIVIDUAL UC CAMPUSES-
LMAO PRODUCT YOU KNOW WHY THIS
WHY NOW KIND OF QUESTION- WHICH
IS UNDERSTANDABLY SO-
UNDERSTANDABLE SO HISTORICALLY
THE ANIMAL YOU. DELEGATED THE
AUTHORITY TO THE STATE FIRE
MARSHAL. OF THE STATE FARM
ACTUALLY EACH CAMPUS WAS ISSUED
A LARGE PART THE PREVIOUS
DEPUTIES OF THE STATE FARM
MARSHALL'S OFFICE WHO WENT TO
THE UC SYSTEM EITHER BY CHOICE
OR BY LAYOFFS THE OPPOSITE SEX
ARMOR. THAT'S STOP WAS OVER IN
THE IN. ROLES AT THE L. S.
OFFENSE AND HAD PART CODES.
PROCESS THERE FOR REALLY HAVING
THAT DEEP UNDERSTANDING OF THE
WISE AND WHAT FORMS OF THE CODES
OF FALL WITHIN THE CHURCH. OF
THE LS. ADDITIONAL DO TO FROM.
RIGHT THEY CAPPING. WITH THE- OS
OFFENSE. AND FREQUENTLY OUT TO
THIS THE ISSUE SEVEN. H. WAY BUT
THE DISCLAIMER FOR THIS I ONE TO
NOTE OUT OF CAUTION DUE TO CIVIL
- OR CRIMINAL LIVES THE- FOR AN
TO DISCUSS SPECIFICS WOULD LIKE-OFFER A HIGH LEVEL. OF AND
INCIDENT REGARDING A DOESN'T
MAKE THE CAMPUS FARMER REACHING
OUT OUR OFFICE TO REPORT THAT
THEY WILL BE. WITHIN A WEEK OF
RETIREMENT WE HAD REACHED NO NOT
. FROM HQ. THEY WERE LOSING
THEIR- CAMPUS MARSHAL. AND WITH
THE LAW CANNOT AND MY TO TAKE
OVER WORK. DILLARD AT THE UC
OFFICE THE PRESS WHO HAS BEEN
HAD BEEN ACTING AS OUR GO
BETWEEN FOUR. EIGHT RESPONSES
BETWEEN THE CAMPUS THE FIRE
MARSHAL'S OFFICE. MUCH LIKE ANY
DOLLAR OF AUTHORITY WITHOUT
SOMEONE WORK WITHIN THAT THE
ONLY. OR THAT DELEGATES IS
SENDING THE AUTHORITY. BACK TO
THE AUTHORITY RESPONSIBLE FOR
THAT ENFORCEMENT. I WAS A FAN
STAFF WAS REASSIGNED TO CAMPUS
TO WORK FROM CURRENT
CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS. ARMY
AMBULANCE. MANY DIFFERENT WERE
IDENTIFIED FOR TO FIRE LIFE
SAFETY INSPECTIONS INSPECTION
AND SPECIFICALLY A BREACH OF THE
MO Q. REGARDING CONTRACTING- OF
SERVICES OUT OF THAT DELEGATE.
OUR STAFF QUICKLY WITH THE UC OF
THE AND OF SOUTH TO PICK THAT UP
BY. THAT WOULD MEET THE
QUALIFICATIONS- THAT ARE
EQUIVALENT TO THE DEBIT TO A
DEPUTY STATE FIRE MARSHAL THE
SPECIALIST CLASSIFICATION.
CANDIDATE WAS CHOSEN BY THE
UNIVERSITY AND THE- SEVERAL MORE
CLOSELY TO TRAIN AND BRING THAT
CANDIDATE UP TO SPEED. ON
CURRENT CAMPUS PROJECTS IN THE
CORRECTIVE ACTIONS- THAT HAD
BEEN PUT IN PLACE BY OUR STAFF.
AS THE ISSUE CAME TO LIGHT. THE
RISK ASSOCIATED WITH THE
DELEGATION WAS REALLY EXPLORED-
BEING THE AUTHORITY TASKED WITH
THE ULTIMATE RESPONSIBILITY FOR
FIRE AND LIFE SAFETY.
SUPERMARKET WAS QUITE CONCERNED
AND MOVE FORWARD WITH THIS
REQUEST- BY WAY OF US BEING
FINANCE LETTER. THERE'S BEEN SIX
A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF TIME AN
ATTRITION IN THE DESIGNATED
CAMPUS FIRE MARSHAL PROGRAM
WHRE MUCH OF THE INSTITUTIONAL
KNOWLEDGE AND THE BOOTS ON THE
GROUND CONNECTIONS WITH THE- SFM
HAVEN'T LOST. YOSEF M. IS ONLY
AWARE OF THE TWENTY EIGHT
DESIGNATED CAMPUS FIRE MARSHALS.
WHO ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR FIRING
MY SAFETY ASPECTS ON ALL
PROPERTIES OWNED OR LEASED BY
THE UC'S- THE WORKLOAD SEEMS
DISPROPORTIONATE TO BE ABLE TO
SUCCESSFULLY MAINTAIN THE
MINIMUM STANDARD THAT ALL OF
THOSE FACILITIES. TO NOTE THAT
DOESN'T A CAMPUS FIRE MARSHALS
ARE EMPLOYED BY THE INDIVIDUAL
CAMPUSES M. WE ALSO OF THOSE
TWENTY EIGHT PEOPLE WE DON'T
KNOW WHAT OTHER DUTIES HAVE BEEN
ASSIGNED TO THEM THROUGH THEIR
CAMPUS CHAIN OF COMMAND.
ANNUALLY WE DO RECEIVE A REPORT
FROM THE UC OFFICE OF THE
PRESIDENT THAT CONSIST OF THE
NUMBER OF CALIFORNIA CODE OF
REGULATIONS TITLE NINETEEN
ENTITLED FOR INSPECTIONS- IF WE
USE IT AS A GOOD STEWARDSHIP- IT
WOULD. IT WOULD DICTATE THAT WE
REVIEWED THOSE LESSER COMPLETED
INSPECTIONS AND PERFORM SPOT
CHECKS- ON THE COOK COMPLAINTS
OF THE CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS OR
EVEN FOLLOW UP ON DEFICIENCIES
THAT WERE- IDENTIFIED BY THOSE
DESIGNATED CAMPUS FIREWATCH.
HOWEVER WITHOUT THIS REQUEST WE
REMAIN STAFFED EFFICIENT TO
PERFORM THIS OVERSIGHT LEAVING
FACULTY STAFF STUDENTS AND THE
FACILITIES WITH AN UNKNOWN
DEGREE OF FIRE AND MIGHT SEEK TO
PUT. MUCH LIKE ANY DELEGATION
WHETHER IT IS A STATE FIRE
MARSHAL. PERSONALLY DELEGATING
ME TO SPEAK TO YOU HERE ON HIS
BEHALF TO PAY MORE THAN
APARTMENT HEALTHCARE ACCESS AND
INFORMATION FORMERLY- ASHKHABAD
DELEGATING AND THEY'RE THIRTY TO
THE UC MEDICAL CENTERS TO
MONITOR THEIR CONSTRUCTION AND-
RENOVATION SEISMIC SAFETY OF
THOSE HOSPITALS AND SKILLED
NURSING FACILITIES. IT ALSO
MEANT RESPONSIBILITY RESPONSIBLE
PARTY IS CHEAP RICH WINE OR THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE ACCESS
INFORMATION JUST AS SOME
COMPARISONS- MY STAFF THAT ONE
OF MY GO TO STATEMENTS IS IT
OKAY TO BE WRONG IT'S PART OF
HEAD OF STATE RUN. AND WE DIDN'T
HAVE STAFFING TO PROVIDE
OVERSIGHT OF THE EXISTING PMR
VIEW BUT NOW THAT SOME OF THOSE
RISKS ASSOCIATED WITH THE LACK
OF OVERSIGHT HAVE BEEN
IDENTIFIED. WE CAN NO LONGER
PROCEED WITHOUT NO OVERSIGHT
COMPONENT. WE REALLY FEEL LIKE
WE NEED TO RESET THAT OVERSIGHT
AND- SOME OF THAT THAT MO YOU
AND IT'S IN. IT'S IMPORTANT TO
POINT OUT BECAUSE I KNOW THAT IT
WAS BROUGHT UP BY THE ALEJO.
THAT THEIR- IDEA WAS THAT THIS
WAS A DUPLICATE OF PROGRAM. IT
IS NOT DEPRESSED DUPLICATE IT IS
SIMPLY AN OVERSIGHT PROGRAM-
THAT IS NEEDED TO PROTECT THE
AUTHORITY DELEGATED- TO THE
OFFICE OF STATE FIRE MARSHAL.
AND THEN FORWARDED ON TO THE UC
CAMPUS- I AM AVAILABLE IF
THERE'S ANY QUESTIONS THANK YOU
. SO TO BE TO BE SURE SURE
UNDERSTAND CURRENTLY THERE ARE
ELEVEN UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA
CAMPUSES CURRENTLY THERE ARE
TWENTY EIGHT DESIGNATED INS
MORE. MARSHALS THAT ARE WORKING
AT THE UC THAT ARE DOING THE
WORK. AT UC MERCED UC RIVERSIDE
IS TO IS THAT CORRECT. HELLO
THERE'S TEN YOU SEE I GOT TEN UC
CAMPUSES FIVE MEDICAL CENTERS
AND ONE NATIONAL LABORATORY- ALL
BEING CONDUCTED AND THOSE ARE
STATE WHETHER THEIR OWN
PROPERTIES OR WHETHER THEY ARE
LEASED PROPERTIES. THOSE ARE
BEING INSPECTED BY TWENTY EIGHT
DESIGNATED CAMPUS FOR MARCIA SO
IN THE PROPOSAL IS THAT YOU
WOULD HAVE TWELVE ADDITIONAL.
MARSHALL'S STEP WITH TO REVIEW
OF THE- REPORTS THAT THEY DO
SPOT INSPECTIONS AND. SO THE
RECORD IS ACTUALLY FOR SIX
THAT'S A GATED CAMPUS FARMERS-
I'M SORRY SIX FIREWORKS WERE FOR
OUR OFFICE AND- ONCE STAFF FOR
OUR H. R. COMPONENT. ONCE
SUPPORT STAFF FOR OUR I. T.
DEPARTMENT AND THE OTHER STAFF
WOULD BE- OF THE GPA AS A LEVEL
THAT WOULD BE ABLE TO- DO A LOT
OF THAT THAT. REVIEW AND
ANALYSIS- FROM OUR DEPUTIES THAT
ARE IN THE FIELDS. AND ON THE
ISSUE THAT WAS RAISED BY THE L.
YOUR GONNA GET TO MISS CARSON
THE CERTIFICATIONS THAT THESE
FOLKS NEED TO DO THEIR JOB IS
IDENTICAL. SO THE WHEN WE MADE
THE L. THE MO YOU TO START WITH
WHAT WE USED TO WAS THE- SAME
HIRING MINIMUM WORK
QUALIFICATIONS. AS ONE OF OUR
DEPUTIES THE RESPECT FOR- AND
THAT IS JUST TO MEET THE MINIMUM
QUALIFICATIONS TO TAKE THE EXAM
TO BECOME- DEPUTY STATE FIRE
MARSHAL. SO THOSE ARE THE
MINIMUM QUALIFICATIONS FOR OUR
STAFF WE CONTINUE TO DO-
APPRENTICESHIP TRAINING
THROUGHOUT AND- CAN NEW
CONSTRUCTION TRAINING-
DIFFERENCE TECHNOLOGIES- THAT
ARE COMING ON SO WE DO
ADDITIONAL TRAINING WITH OUR
DEPUTIES THE FARMER. OKAY MISS
CURSING WITH THE L. A. O. HE
FELT THE BENEFIT AT THIS
PRESENTATION WHICH IS ADDED SOME
MORE. INFORMATION IF YOU'RE
YOU'RE RECOMMENDATION IS WAS
INSUFFICIENT JUSTIFICATION-
PLEASE PROCEED. THANK YOU SO
MUCH AND I CHAIR AND SENATORS SO
WE'RE RECOMMENDING REJECTING THE
PROPOSAL BECAUSE WE FIND THAT
THE FIRE MARSHAL HASN'T
ADEQUATELY JUSTIFIED THE NEED
FOR THE REQUESTING UNIT AND IT'S
THIS EXACTLY WE HAVEN'T RECEIVED
SPECIFIC EVIDENCE TO
SUBSTANTIATE THAT YOU SEE
CURRENTLY FAILS TO ADEQUATELY
ENFORCE BUILDING STANDARDS AT
ITS CAMPUSES AND WE HEARD A
LITTLE BIT- YOU KNOW ABOUT. ONCE
CAN'T THIS POTENTIALLY THAT MAY
HAVE HAVE HAD AN ISSUE- WE
HAVEN'T HAD ANY INFORMATION
RECEIVED ANY INFORMATION YET-
ABOUT WHETHER THIS IS YOU HAVE
TO BRING THAT ISSUE IS AND ALSO
JUST HOW WIDESPREAD THAT IS SO
IS THAT REALLY JUST RELATED TO
THIS ONE CAMPUS THAT HAD
SIGNIFICANT BUILDING. PROGRAM
AND HAD SOMEONE RETIREES IS A
MORE WIDESPREAD ISSUE AND SO
THAT'S ONE ISSUE AND IT'S ALSO
NOT CLEAR A TAD- WHETHER A NEW
DEDICATED UNIT AS IS PROPOSED IS
REALLY THE MOST APPROPRIATE
APPROACH TO ADDRESSING. THE
ISSUES IF ANY- BETTER IF THEY
ARE SIGNIFICANT YOU SEE- YES YES
HI DELEGATED AUTHORITY FOR QUITE
SOME TIME SO WHILE THE STATUTORY
AUTHORITY UNDERPINNING THIS IMHO
YOU IT'S FROM TWO THOUSAND AND
TEN OUR UNDERSTANDING IS THAT
YOU SEE IS HAD THIS DELEGATED
AUTHORITY SINCE NINETEEN NINETY
FOUR. SO IT'S BEEN ALMOST THIRTY
YEARS THAT YOU SEE IS HAD THIS
DELEGATED AUTHORITY TO DO THESE-
INSPECTIONS AT THEIR CAMPUSES.
SO- IT IS IT'S ON THAT WHETHER
YOU KNOW WHAT. IT A REALLY. SORT
OF THE SECOND LAYER ISN'T IT IS
THE APPROACH MIGHT BE- BUT THERE
COULD BE A THINGS COULD BE CAN.
I SO YOU KNOW WE ALSO. THAT ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT YOU OUR
REVIEW CAME UP AS WE DID TALK TO
YOU SEE- AND HAD SOME
CORRESPONDENCE WITH YOU SEE AND
THEY RAISED A NUMBER OF CONCERNS
ABOUT THE PROPOSAL- YOU KNOW. IN
THEIR MINDS IF THEY DIDN'T FEEL
IT BUT IT WAS WARRANTED IS WHAT
WE HEARD IN ME WE HEARD THAT
THEIR CONCERN WAS THAT IT WAS
DUPLICATIVE. I'M AND IT WOULD
TAKE ADDITIONAL STAFF RESOURCES
ON THEIR PART TO STUDENTS TODAY
TO- BE INVOLVED IN IN THIS SORT
OF. PROGRAM THAT WOULD HAVE THIS
EXTRA LAYER FOR THEM SO THAT
THAT WAS WHAT WE HEARD FROM
THEM. AGAIN WE DON'T YOU KNOW I
THINK THERE'S A LOT WE DON'T
KNOW AND SO FAR RIGHT THE
RATIONALE FOR URBAN REJECTING AT
THIS TIME IS TO GIVE EVERYONE A
LITTLE BIT MORE TIME TO THINK
ISRAEL WE'RE- YOU KNOW WE'RE IN
APRIL THE END OF APRIL. ALMOST
MAY- YOU KNOW AS THE COMMITTEE
WELL KNOWS THIS THE END OF THIS
PROCESS GOES SO QUICKLY- AND SO
WE THINK THAT IF THE
ADMINISTRATION WANTS TO COME
BACK IN JANUARY THAT WOULD GIVE
THEM MORE TIME TO PROVIDE AN
ADDITIONAL AN- ADDITIONAL
RATIONALE. IT'LL ALSO GIVE SOME
ADDITIONAL TIME TO WORK WITH YOU
SEE TO DETERMINE WHETHER OR NOT
THE CONCERNS THAT THEY RAISED
ARE MERITORIOUS- WERE NOT.
INTENDED TO REALLY HOPEFULLY
COME TO A CONSENSUS THIS ISSUE.
I'M SO- HAVE YOU TAKEN BY.
MISTER BENSON PART FINANCE CHIEF
ANYTHING YOU WOULD TO ADD. THANK
YOU SURE ASSUME. HARBOR IF I.
HIS RESPONSE. ONE POINT OUT THAT
. THE OF THESE THREE. ARE IS. TO
HELP FIGHT. HOW WHITES THE
PROBLEMS THAT. YOU IN THAT
DENTISTS LIKE. IS SHE SAID YOU
KNOW. ONE OF THE THINGS THEY
JUST. IS THE A FEW. OKAY TO BE
WRONG IT'S THE NOT OKAY CONTINUE
BEING WRONG THINK WHICH IS NOW.
IN HIS THAT. NO THEY HAVEN'T
BEEN BACK TO. LOW OR SAY THEY
SHOULD AND AS THEY HAD STEP IN
AND- THE CAMP THAT YOU'RE- TO
THE DISCOVERED SOMETHING. AND
WITHOUT THE IMPROPER LEVEL OF
OVER. TO GO INTO AND DO. CHECKS
AND- WE MAY NOT KNOW. HOW PRO
SOME OF THE CONCERNS ARE THERE
NEEDS TO BE CORPORATE. ELSE'S
WAY TO REITERATE THAT THIS.
DOESN'T CREATE ANY REDUNDANT.
THE DESIGNATED CAMPUS FARMERS.
WILL CONTINUE TO DO ALL OF THE
PLAN REVIEW. PHILIPPINES SECTION
TO. BUILDINGS FOR. ON THERE CAN
. WHAT IT PRICE. IT'S A LEVEL OF
THE- OBJECTIVE. OR TO REVIEW NEW
SPOT CHECKS. ANNUAL CHECK INS.
TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY FIREMEN.
BUILDING CODE REQUIREMENTS- BE
MET. HOW WE FEEL THAT GIVE THE
SIX. PUBLIC AND HOW PUBLIC
HEALTH AND SAFETY CONSIDERATIONS
WITH THE STUDENTS AND STAFF AND
FACULTY THAT THAT UC'S CAMPUSES
BUT THIS LEVEL OVER SCIENCE
CORPORATION. TIME WE DON'T
BELIEVE THE PLACES ANY UNDUE
BURDEN ON THE UC CAMPUS STATE
FARM PERSONAL BILLS AND HOURLY
RATE. THIS WILL ONLY BE BILLED
FOR THE COST OF THE HOURS THAT
ARE NECESSARY TO PERFORM
APPROPRIATE OVERSIGHT AT THEIR
CAMPUSES SO OF CODE COMPLIANCE
IS BEING DONE APPROPRIATELY THAT
WILL BE A VERY MODEST IN NORMAL
AMOUNT OF. TIME IN THERE FOR A
VERY MODEST YOU KNOW A LOT OF
COST THE ONLY WAY THEY WOULD BE
SIGNIFICANT COST AS IF THE
FAUCET FARMERS DISCOVERED THAT
THINGS ARE NOT BEING. SO WE
RESPECTFULLY. THAT THE COMMITTEE
CONSIDER APPROVING THIS REQUEST
TODAY OR AT LEAST HOLDING IT
OPEN SO WE CAN CONTINUE
CONVERSATIONS OVER THE NEXT WEEK
OR SO- AND- ADDRESS THE ISSUE
HAS OTHER ISSUES TO CLOSE OUT
THIS. WEBSITE THANK YOU SEND
REQUIRED QUESTION. THANK YOU SO
MUCH IT. I'M MORE OF A COMMON IF
IT'S ALREADY- MISS CHAIRS SO LOW
FOR SOME US I THINK THAT WE CAN
AGREE THAT THE STATE FARM
MARSHAL'S. PROVIDES CRITICAL
SERVICES ACROSS THE STATE THAT
KEEPS CALIFORNIANS SAFE KEEPS
OUR STATE AGENCIES- ACCOUNTABLE
MAKING SURE THAT THEIR MEETING
PUBLIC SAFETY NEEDS. SINCE THE
TWO THOUSANDS THE OFFICE HAS
BEEN TASKED TO SUPPORT
THEMSELVES BASED ON FEES AS WE
CONTINUE TO SEE TODAY. BUT IT IS
NOT A SUSTAINABLE STRATEGY AND
THERE ARE SOME REAL CHALLENGES
WITH APPROACHING THIS WITH A FEE
BASED STRATEGY. AND IT IS LEAD
TO NEGATIVE CONSEQUENCES ACROSS
THE GOLDEN STATE I WANT TO TALK
ABOUT THE ISSUE OF SMALL FAIRS
AND I WANT TO TALK ABOUT WHAT A
SOLUTION COULD BE. SO FIRST AND
FOREMOST WHAT WE SEE WITH THE
STATE FARM MARSHAL'S OFFICE AND
I WANT TO THANK YOU SO MUCH IS
STATE FARM MARSHAL'S OFFICE FOR
ENGAGING ON THIS ISSUE. SMALL
FAIRS ACROSS THE STATE FACE HIGH
FEES FROM THE OFFICE OF STATE
FIRE MARSHAL FOR EVENTS. THAT
THEY HAVE TO HAVE THE BEER
SUPPORT THEMSELVES AFTER THE
STATE STOP SUPPORTING FARES. ANY
CURRENT INSPECTION RATE FROM THE
FIRE MARSHAL'S OFFICE IS TWO
HUNDRED AND FORTY DOLLARS AN
HOUR. THE FIRE MARSHAL IS
CURRENTLY WORKING ON A REVISED
FRAMEWORK AND I WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU TRULY THIS IS NOT
THROWING STONES AT THE FARMERS
CHAU OR SAY THANK YOU FOR
WORKING ON THIS THAT WOULD
REQUIRE AN EIGHT HOUR EIGHT HOUR
PARTY WITH FIVE HUNDRED PEOPLE.
IF YOU'RE GOING TO THE TRINITY
COUNTY FAIR. WITH LESS THAN
SIXTEEN THOUSAND PEOPLE IN THE
COUNTY IF YOU WANT TO HAVE
EIGHTY EIGHT OUR PARTY WITH FIVE
HUNDRED PEOPLE YOU'RE SPENDING
FOUR THOUSAND DOLLARS JUST TO
COVER THE COST OF THE FIRE
MARSHAL. FOUR THOUSAND DOLLARS
NOW WE HAVE A GREAT IDEA WHY
DON'T WE SAT IN THE UC SYSTEM
WITH THE SAME STRATEGY SO THIS
CREATES A DISINCENTIVE CANDIDLY
FOR SMALL STATE AGENCIES OR
LARGE STATE AGENCIES- TO BE ABLE
TO ABIDE BY  T
BECAUSE IF THEY'RE GONNA BY BY
STATE LAW NO ONE'S GONNA BOOK
THEIR BOOK THEIR HOLES THERE ARE
GONNA BOOK THE HOLES BEFORE
BEFORE THEY EVEN GET TO THE
PRICE OF THE HALL THERE'S BEEN
AN FOUR THOUSAND DOLLARS TO
COVER THE COST OF THE STATE FIRE
MARSHAL. ALL THEY SAID IS IT IS
FINALLY IS THAT WE NEED TO GET
AWAY FROM A FEE BASED FUNDING-
ST STRATEGY TO SUPPORT THE
OFFICE THE STATE FIRE MARSHAL
WE'VE DONE THIS FOR OVER A
DECADE NOW IT DOESN'T WORK IT'S
ANTIQUATED IN ITS PUNITIVE AND I
WOULD HOPE THAT NGUYEN THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE BRINGS
BACK- OVERALL STRATEGY IT'S
INVESTING GENERAL FUND DOLLARS
AS WE SHOULD BE INTO THE STATE
FARM MARSHAL'S OFFICE AND I JUST
WANNA SAY THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
SECURE FROM THE INTELLIGENCE.
CENTER DOLLY. TWELVE LOVE
HAVEN'T CENTER FROM THE SEC
DISTRICT ON COULD YOU EVER RULE
- FARES AS WELL THE POINT OF
THIS IS THAT WE SHOULD ALLOW WE
SHOULD ALLOW THE LOCAL FIRE
MARSHAL. UNDERNEATH THE STATE
FIRE MARSHAL TO BE ABLE TO GO IN
AND DO THOSE INSPECTIONS SO THAT
WE DON'T HAVE TO HAVE AN TRAVEL
IN SOME CASES. A HALF A DAY TO
GET TO THE SITE EVEN WHICH A
CHARGE FOR SO I THINK WE SHOULD
I THINK OF THE STATE FIRE
MARSHAL SHOULD ALLOW THE LOCALS
TO. HAVE THEIR LOCAL FIRE
MARSHAL THE CERTIFY THEM. THANK
YOU ALL SEEING THE WEATHER
QUESTIONS BY MEMBERS SEE
SEPARATE RENDITION IS TO REJECT
THIS. CALL BACK. AND CONTINUED
COP CONVERSATIONS SERVE YOU GOT
SOME FEEDBACK FROM- THAT THE
SUBCOMMITTEE ON THAT. VERY GOOD
LET'S MOVE TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME WAS MOVED TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF PARKS RECREATION THIS IS
ISSUE NUMBER THIRTY TWO IS A
STATE WIDE BUDGET- PACKAGE IN
STUDIES. AND WE HAVE A MISTER DO
WE USE ASSISTANT DIRECTOR. AS
WELL AS- OUR FRIENDS AT
FINANCING ALLEY ON. FIVE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR WE GOOD MORNING. YOU'RE
A MEASURE MEMBERS- HELLO MY NAME
IS BRIAN DUTY ON THE STREETS OF
FACILITIES AND DEVELOPMENT FOR
CALIFORNIA STATE PARKS- I'D LIKE
TO THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PROVIDE A BRIEF OVERVIEW OF
THIS PROPOSAL- BERMAN HAS A
SIGNIFICAN WELL DOCUMENTED
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS AS
DESCRIBED IN THE STAFF REPORT-
WELL WE HAVE NOT SELECTED A LIST
OF CAPITAL OUTLAY PROPOSALS TO
BE TO. DEVELOP FURTHER WITH THIS
FUNDING WE EXPECT THE PROJECT TO
BE HEAVILY FOCUSED ON ADDRESSING
EXISTING INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS
INCLUDING HEALTH AND SAFETY
ACCESS DEFERRED MAINTENANCE CODE
COMPLIANCE AND OPERATIONAL
IMPROEMENTS. IMPORTANT NOTE
THAT CAPABLY PROJECTS ARE
ESSENTIAL OF THE DRESSING THE-
DIVERS INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS AND
COMMONLY INCLUDE OTHER PROJECT
CATEGORIES SUCH AS DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE ELEMENTS AS WELL AS
EXPANDED OR IMPROVED FACILITIES.
TO REFLECT CHANGING VISITATION
PATTERNS AND USER NEEDS. THE
PROPOSED FUNDS WILL BE USED TO
CONDUCT DETAILED STUDIES AND
INVESTIGATIONS INCLUDING
GEOTECHNICAL STUDIES NATURAL AND
CULTURAL RESOURCE INVENTORIES.
AND THESE EFFORTS WILL ALSO HELP
INFORM PRIMARY DESIGN CONCEPTS
UNIT TO DEVELOP DETAILED COST
ESTIMATES INSCRIPTIONS THAT WILL
BE USED TO PROVIDE HIGHER
QUALITY BUDGET PROPOSALS FOR
FUTURE CONSIDERATION. BY THE
LEGISLATURE TO THE ANNUAL BUDGET
PROCESS THIS INFORMATION WILL
ALSO ENABLE THE DEPARTMENT TO
EXPEDITE THE LENGTHY PERMITTING
PROCESS RESULTING IN SHORTER
PROJECT DELIVERY SCHEDULES BY
MAKING IT POSSIBLE TO ENGAGE
PERMITTED AGENCIES EARLIER IN IN
THE PROCESS. AND WOULD THAT THIS
CONCLUDES MY PREPARED REMARKS
AND I HAD THE ANSWER THE
QUESTIONS THAT YOU MAY HAVE.
THANK YOU. KRISTIN YOUR THOUGHTS
. WE DON'T HAVE ANY SPECIFIC
CONCERNS ON THIS PROPOSAL WE
JUST KNOW THAT SEEKS IN THE
LEGISLATURE HAS PRIORITIES FOR
FUTURE PROJECTS THAT THE
DEPARTMENT UNDERTAKES IT COULD
CERTAINLY CONSIDER PROVIDING
THAT DIRECTIONS THE DEPARTMENT
BECAUSE THIS FUNDING WILL BE
USED FOR THOSE PLANNING
ACTIVITIES AND THEN LIKELY
LEGISLATURE WILL SEE THOSE
PROJECTS COME FORWARD SO THAT'S
JUST SOMETHING TO THINK ABOUT
AND I KNOW THIS COMMITTEE HAS
HAS TALKED IN THE PAST ABOUT
SOME OF ITS PRIORITIES- WITH
REGARD TO PARTS INFRASTRUCTURE
SO AND IT'S JUST LIKE THAT FOR
YOU BUT BUT NO SPECIFIC CONCERNS
WE THINK IT'S REASONABLE TO SEND
THE MONEY. I'M DOING THIS
INITIAL DESIGN WORK AND GETTING
A REALLY BETTER YOU KNOW A
BETTER SENSE THE COST ESTIMATES
BEFORE THE DEPARTMENT COMES
FORWARD WITH IT THEIR SPECIFIC
PROPOSALS- MCGINNIS- MISS-
MITTERRAND- I FINANCE. I DO I
KNOW YOU GUYS WILL PROBABLY GET
YOUR- EMAIL THAT THE SENATE
DEMOCRATS HAVE ANNOUNCED THEIR
NEW BUDGET PROPOSAL WHICH
INCLUDES. EIGHTEEN BILLION
DOLLARS AND CLIMATE ADAPTATION
PROJECTS WHICH INCLUDES MONEY
FOR INFRASTRUCTURE- TO THE PARKS
AND I'LL LET YOU GUYS. OPEN UP
YOUR EMAIL AND READ DAT. AS IN
WE'RE IN THERE ARE CURRENT
BUDGET YEAR WE HAVE A HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY FIVE. MILLION DEBT
THAT WAS IS DEDICATED FOR THE
BACKLOG OF DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
THAT WE HAVE SO WHAT WE THINK
IT'S- THIS PROPOSAL IS GOOD
THIRTY THIRD LOOK AT EVERYTHING-
IN IN. TOTALITY AND OBVIOUSLY WE
HAVE SOME CONCERNS WERE YOU
HAVE- YOU KNOW- CLIMATE IMPACTS
ON ON THE PARKS DO YOU HAVE ANY-
STAFF RECOMMENDATION IS TO HOLD
THIS UP AND HAVE ANY. THING
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS YOU'D LIKE
TO SHARE WITH THE SUBCOMMITTEE.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON- SENATORS AND-
MY NAME IS THE STOCK NUMBER THAT
I KNOW WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE WE HAVE NO COMMENTS ON
THE SENATE PROPOSAL AT THIS AT
THIS TIME. ALL I KNOW THAT I YET
JUST SAYING WE'RE GOING TO
YOU'LL BE BACK HERE YOU'LL BE
BACK HERE FINANCE IN THE COMING
YEARS AND WILL HAVE A SPECIAL
HEARING ON THE BUDGET PROPOSAL
I'M JUST GIVING YOU A HEADS UP
RIGHT BECAUSE THIS IS RATHER
MODEST AND IT'S WE'RE GONNA HOLD
IT OPEN- WE LOOK AT THE
DIFFERENT. CATEGORIES DEPUTY
DIRECTOR DR DO WE BUT I I'M NOT
GONNA SPEAK FOR THE OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE BUT
YOU'VE HEARD THEM BEFORE HI
THERE YOU KNOW- IT'S A ONE POINT
TWO BILLION DOLLARS DEATH-
BACKLOG AND DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
AND WE PUT A CHUNK IN LAST YEAR.
AND I GUESS TO BE NOT SO
ELOQUENT WITH LIKE ANOTHER CHUNK
FOR THE NEXT. COUPLE OF YEARS SO
TO LOOK AT IT. C. NO. THE
QUESTION WILL GET A WHOLE THIS
MATTER OPEN THANK GUYS FOR- THE
FOR THE INPUT AND WILL MOVE TO.
A ISSUE NUMBER THIRTY THREE THIS
IS WHEN THE DEPARTMENT OF FISH
AND WILDLIFE. AS WELL AS WE HAVE
A CALTRANS WHO'S AVAILABLE- THIS
IS- THE WILDLIFE CONNECTIVITY
ACTIONS. COMPENSATORY MITIGATION
CRITICISES SPRANG OUT OF- SB
SEVEN NINE OH WITH SENATOR STERN
AND CORTICES- THE DIRECTOR. OF
BOTTOM. GOOD MORNING WELCOME.
THANK YOU CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS- IT'S TRUE MY NAME'S
CHUCK BONHAM. AND I'M THE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF FISH WILDLIFE. THE
DEPARTMENT REQUESTED A PRETTY
MODEST. ADDITIONAL FREE
PERMANENT POSITIONS. AND SEVEN
HUNDRED AND SEVENTEEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS FOR GENERAL FUND. FOR
FISCAL YEAR TWENTY TWO TO TWENTY
THREE. AND TWO ADDITIONAL
PERMANENT POSITIONS AT ONE POINT
ONE MILLION DOLLARS IN FISCAL
YEAR TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR
ONGOING. SO WHY DO WE MAKE THAT
REQUEST. IS TO IMPLEMENT THE
BILL YOU JUST REFERENCE SENATE
BILL SEVEN NINETY THE AUTHORS IN
THE IN THE CHAMBER. AND WHAT IS
THAT BILL ABOUT IT'S ABOUT-
SURMOUNTABLE CHALLENGE CURRENT
INFRASTRUCTURE IN CALIFORNIA AND
FUTURE INFRASTRUCTURE IN
CALIFORNIA HAS THE POTENTIAL TO
ELIMINATE OR DIMINISH THE
ABILITY FOR WILDLIFE TO ROAM.
AND THAT IS THE PHRASE
CONNECTIVITY THAT IS IN THE
TITLE OF THE BILL IT'S THE
SUBJECT OF THE BILL AND THE BILL
WILL ALLOW OUR DEPARTMENT TO
PRODUCE A SERIES OF GUIDELINES
THAT CREATED ECONOMICS
INCENTIVES. FOR TRANSPORTATION
AND INFRASTRUCTURE TO INCLUDE
CONNECTIVITY IN THEIR PROPOSALS
AND PROJECTS AND OUR DEPARTMENT
CAN GIVE CREDIT FOR THAT IN THE
REGULATORY SPACE THAT EXISTS
AROUND IMPACTS AND MITIGATIONS
UNDER LAW WHAT ARE THE BENEFITS.
IT'S DEFINITELY A CLIMATE
ADAPTATION STRATEGY IT PRODUCES
PUBLIC BENEFITS THE SINGLE
BIGGEST BECAUSE OF WILDLIFE
MORTALITY IN THE STATE IS
VEHICLE COLLISIONS WHICH CREATES
AN INCREASED INSURANCE BURDEN ON
CITIZENS AS WELL. YOU GET A
BENEFIT FROM ECONOMIC INCENTIVES
IT'S AN INCENTIVE DRIVEN
APPROACH THROUGH CREDITS RATHER
THAN A FEE BASED APPROACH AND OF
COURSE YOU GET WILDLIFE BENEFITS. TWO EXAMPLES THAT PROVE THE
BENEFITS. LAST WEEK US SENATOR
STERN- THE GOVERNOR AND OTHERS
CELEBRATED THE LAUNCH TO THE-
GREAT LEADERSHIP OF LAW CENTER
BIRDS FOUNDATION SOMETHING
CALLED THE WALLIS ANNENBERG
WILDLIFE CROSSING IN LOS
ANGELES. IT'LL BE THE WORLD'S
LARGEST WILDLIFE CROSSING ACROSS
HIGHWAY ONE OH ONE. IT IS
PERHAPS OUR LAST BEST CHANCE TO
CURE ALL INFRASTRUCTURE AND
PREVENT EXTINCTION OF A MOUNTAIN
LION POPULATION THAT'S ISOLATED
BECAUSE OF THOSE COUNTLESS LANES
OF HIGHWAY ONE ON ONE. AND BACK
IN MARCH SECOND EXAMPLE THE NEW
YORK TIMES AND WASHINGTON POST.
PUBLISHED A SERIES OF MAPS
ILLUSTRATING THE NATURAL WEALTH
OF EACH STATE IN THESE UNITED
STATES. AND WHAT THOSE MAPS SHOW
IS IN CALIFORNIA WE HAVE THE
HIGHEST AMOUNT OF NATURAL
WEALTH. BUT WE ALSO HOME TO THE
MOST IMPERILLED AMOUNT OF
SPECIES. SO WILDLIFE
CONNECTIVITY IMPLEMENTING SB.
SEVEN NINETY IS A GOOD THING TO
DO. AND WE APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT OUR
REQUEST TO YOU THIS MORNING.
THANK YOU- MISS AYLER SWEATER
THE L. A. O. DO YOU HAVE
ANYTHING TO ADD. AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS AT NO
COMMENTS FROM US AND WE DIDN'T
RAISE ANY CONCERNS WITH THIS
PROPOSAL THANK YOU. DO WE HAVE
FROM. DEPUTY CHIEF DIVISION SEAT
CHIEF KETCHUM AND DUNCAN ONLINE
I'M LOOKING AT MY COMPUTER. I'D
DO YOU GO ALL RIGHT- BEFORE GET
TO FINANCE ANYTHING TO ADD HERE
. MERION CAPITAL IN DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE NOTHING TO HIDE THANK
YOU TO THE DIRECTOR FOR YOUR
COMMENTS AND HERE TO HELP ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS OKAY- I KNOW
CENTER STERN HAS QUESTION SO.
SENATOR HERE RECOGNIZE- THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND THANK YOU
DIRECTOR BOTTOM FOR YOUR- YOUR
PRESENTATION- IT WAS A HISTORIC
DAY AT LAST WEEK AND WE
APPRECIATE THE LEADERSHIP OF
THIS ADMINISTRATION WHEN IT
COMES TO WILDLIFE CONNECTIVITY
AND TRULY BREAKING NEW GROUND-
IN REWILDING OUR BUILT
INFRASTRUCTURE TO ALLOW SOME
SOME HOPE FOR SUCH AS THE
MONALISA SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
BUT- FOR ALL THE- SHE'S THAT
ARE. ENDANGERED OR OTHERWISE
ISOLATED THROUGHOUT THE STATE- I
WANTED TO GET A SENSE. YOU KNOW
WITH THIS ONE BRIDGE WILL NOT DO
IT. AS EXCITING AS LAST WEEK WAS
WE KNOW THAT. WE'RE GONNA NEED
MORE CROSSINGS MORE LINKAGE
WE'RE STAE THAT DRIVES AT HIGH
SPEEDS IN MANY PLACES THAT ARE
WILD PLACES- I WANTED TO GET A
SENSE FROM YOU AND IDEALLY ALSO
FROM. THE DEPARTMENT
TRANSPORTATION WHO I REALLY
APPRECIATE JOINING THE HEARING
AND BEING ON THE LINE- THE
GOVERNOR'S SORT OF. HOW THIS
FITS INTO THE GOVERNOR'S BIG
BIGGER VISION ON IMPLEMENTING
THIRTY BY THIRTY AND-
BIODIVERSITY. AND THE SORT OF
BROADER WILD WILDLIFE
CONNECTIVITY PROPOSALS THAT THAT
ARE BEING PUT FORTH IN THE
BUDGET- THEN JUST PUT A FINER
POINT ON THAT- THESE ARE THESE
ARE- SPECIFIED IS COMPENSATORY
MITIGATION CREDITS. BUT I'M
REALLY HOPING TO GET A TIMELINE
ON WHEN THE GUIDELINES. WILL BE.
COMPLETED AND HOW SOON FUNDING
WILL BE EMERGING FROM FROM THIS
FRAMEWORK- BUT WE KNOW THERE ARE
A NUMBER OF CONSTRUCTION
PROJECTS UNDERWAY RIGHT NOW
AROUND THE STATE- AND- I'M
WONDERING IF THOSE PROJECTS ARE
ARE JUST GONNA BE MOVING FORWARD
WITHOUT ANY- WITHOUT TAKING
ADVANTAGE OF THIS PROGRAM. OR
ANY SORT OF COMPENSATORY
MITIGATION FUNDING- FOR CURRENT. PROJECTS UNDERWAY OR FOR.
EDGEX ANTICIPATED IN THE YEAR
DURING THE PENDENCY OF THESE
GUIDELINES. GREAT QUESTION
CENTER AND- LET'S TAKE A STAB
AND THEN SEE IF OUR CALTRANS
COLLEAGUES HAVE ANYTHING TO.
RECTOR AT. IT FITS REALLY WELL
SO THE BUDGET PROPOSAL AND YOUR
BILL SIT SQUARELY AND MY VIEW OF
WHERE THIS ADMINISTRATION WANTS
TO HEAD. AND IT FITS IN A
VARIETY OF WAYS YOU MENTIONED
THIRTY BY THIRTY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT'S ANALOG IS AMERICA
THE BEAUTIFUL- WE ARE IN A
BIODIVERSITY CRISIS AS YOU
ELOQUENTLY STATED LAST WEEK EACH
CITIZEN HAS A RIGHT TO A
THRIVING NATURE. AND
CONNECTIVITY HELPS US GET THERE.
IT SITS REALLY WELL AND NATURE
BASED SOLUTIONS WHICH YOU'VE
HEARD SECRETARY CROWFOOT TALK
ABOUT AND JUST LAST FRIDAY. I
THINK THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
POSTED- BUDGET PROPOSAL FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION IN THAT SPACE AND
THERE'S AN ADDITIONAL FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS TO OUR
DEPARTMENT SPECIFICALLY FOR
CORRIDORS AND CONNECTIVITY. SO
IN THE PAST I'VE HAD MOMENTS
WHERE WE'VE HAD GREAT IDEAS BUT
NO FUNDING. NOW WE HAVE REALLY
GOOD IDEAS AND THE FINANCIAL
CAPACITY TO GET MORE OF THESE
TYPES OF PROJECTS DONE. BUT IT'S
AN INCENTIVE BASED APPROACH SO
IT FITS WELL BOTH IN THE SENSE
OF THINKING ABOUT WHAT OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE FOOTPRINT IS
BUILDING OUT TO BE AND HOW IT'S
MODERNIZE IT. AND DOING THAT IN
A WAY THAT FUTURE PROOFS US IF
WE DON'T LEAVE ROOM TO ROAM FOR
ANIMALS CLIMATE CHANGE AND BAR
HARDSCAPE. WILL CONTRIBUTE TO
EXTINCTION OF SPECIES IN THE
STATE. IT ALSO FITS IN A CONTEXT
OF- WHAT GOVERNOR. NEWSOM IN
SECRETARY CRAWFORD OF ADVANCING
WHICH IS CUTTING THE GREEN TAPE
TO GET MORE ENVIRONMENTALLY GOOD
PROJECTS DONE FASTER OFTEN MY
DEPARTMENT IS A HANG UP IN THAT
SPACE. AND WE'RE LOOKING AT
IMPLEMENTING SB SEVEN NINETY AS
A WAY TO GIVE A BENEFIT TO A
SISTER AGENCY LIKE CALTRANS OR
OTHER INFRASTRUCTURE
DEVELOPMENT. SOMETIME ON. I'M
GOING TO STAY PERSONALLY
INVOLVED IN THIS BECAUSE I DON'T
WANT TO LOSE THE ABILITY TO
OFFER CREDITS WHILE WE'RE MOVING
PROJECTS TO THE CURRENT PIPELINE
LET ALONE THE FUTURE PIPELINE.
SO I HOPE IT'S LESS THAN A YEAR
TO DO GUIDELINES WE'VE ALREADY
STARTED TO GET READY. ON THE
KIND OF FINGERS CROSSED WE'LL
SEE THIS FUNDING YOU KNOW COME
JULY ONE. IN I'LL GIVE YOU A
FLAVOUR OF PLACES THAT COULD
BENEFIT WITHOUT TRYING TO. A
COMMITMENT TODAY SENATOR DOLLARS
IT'S VERY THE STATE ONE OF OUR
MOST MAJESTIC DEER HERDS UP IN
THE LOYALTON HEARD AS YOU GO
NORTH ON EIGHTY NINE- THAT'S A
PLACE WE CAN LOOK AT
CONNECTIVITY IN COURT OR TO GO
ON THE EAST SIDE OF THIS YEAR'S
THREE NINETY FIVE HAS INCREDIBLE
ANTELOPE HERDS THAT HUNTERS LOVE
THAT RELATE TO CONNECTIVITY
CHALLENGES DOWN IN THE HOBBY
DESERT BETWEEN ST LOS ANGELES
AND LAS VEGAS WE'VE GOT. I
CONDUCT DESERT BIGHORN SHEEP
POPULATIONS ON EITHER SIDE OF
THE FEDERAL HIGHWAY YOU GO UP
INTO THE BAY AREA THE MOST
DEADLY STRETCH OF HIGHWAY IN
CALIFORNIA FROM AN ANIMAL
MORTALITY PERSPECTIVE IS WHEN
YOU LEAVE THE BAY AREA AND YOU
DRIVE DOWN THE PALO ALTO IN TWO
EIGHTY- WE'VE GOT. A MALE
ALLIANCE. YOU THINK OR THE
TEMECULA AREA. ALL THOSE THINGS
ARE FIXABLE. WHEN YOU HAVE
FUNDING. PARTNERSHIPS CREATIVE
THINKING AND REGULATORY KIND OF
MARKET DRIVEN INCENTIVES LIKE
YOUR BILL PROPOSES THANKS FOR
THE TIME. CALTRANS. YEAH I AM I
WOULD CALTRANS- AND I'M- HAPPY
TO BE HERE TO SUPPORT YOU HAVE
W. WE HAVE A GREAT PARTNERSHIP
WITH EDF W. WE'VE BEEN WORKING
IN MANY ARENAS WITH THEM ALL THE
WHILE THAT CONNECTIVE ITTY ISSUE
ALREADY- THIS IS AN AREA WHICH
THE DIRECTOR BOTTOM MENTIONED
WHERE THE CALTRANS WOULD BE A
BENEFICIARY OF THE CREDITS THAT
ARE- CREATED SO- BUT WE WOULD
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT. THEY ARE
USEFUL CREDIT SO- WORKING
TOGETHER- TO PROVIDE SUPPORT
AND- INSURE THAT- THE CREDITS
ARE USEFUL I THINK IT'S
DEFINITELY SOMETHING THAT WE'LL
BE LOOKING TO PARTNER WITH THE
SHE GET HELP ON THE PART OF FISH
WILDLIFE- SENATORS. MENTIONED
THE MEDICATION AT BUT THE
LARGEST OF THIS- WHILE I'VE
CONNECT TO THE- MEDICATIONS
AFTER. THERE'S ALSO A ROOM FOR.
IN TERMS OF ENHANCEMENT AND
GRANTS THERE'S- FUNDING THAT'S
COMING AVAILABLE FROM THE
FEDERAL STANDPOINT SO WE'RE
DOING A LOT OF INVENTORY WORK TO
IDENTIFY WHERE THESE HOTSPOTS
ARE LOCATED. IN THE WILL BE A
WELCOME. TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
ANY GRANT OPPORTUNITIES THAT
COME BAILABLE AND ALSO BE ABLE
TO UTILIZE- ANY OTHER
MITIGATION. OPPORTUNITIES AS
WELL SO THERE'S- BOTH HAVE BEEN
AND THE MITIGATION. AND WE'RE
LOOKING AT BOTH OF THOSE ANGLES-
TO MAXIMIZE THEIR OPPORTUNITIES
. DIRECTOR BOTTOM ALSO TALKED
ABOUT- SOME OF LARGE MAMMALS
THERE'S ALSO A LOT OF
OPPORTUNITY. FOR ALL. AND OTHER
SPECIES. THAT WILL USE. MAYBE
EVEN ON CROSS. MUCH COST BUT A
LOT OF BENEFITS THE SPECIES THAT
WE LOOK FORWARD TO. FURTHER
PARTNERING AND ABLE TO WORK ON
THIS ISSUE AND MAKE A BIG
DIFFERENCE. THANKS FOR THAT THE
COMMUNIST CATCH HIM AND- PRETTY
YOU KNOW THAT THE GOVERNOR JOKED
LAST WEEK THAT IT'S NOT OFTEN
EVERYONE STANDS UP AND APPLAUDS
CALTRANS FOOT- IN- YOU KNOW EVEN
AMONG THE PUBLIC YOU HAVE PEOPLE
ALL THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA- APPLAUDING YOU FOR
THIS SORT OF- DEVOLVE WAY
LOOKING AT INFRASTRUCTURE
DEVELOPMENT SO. BUT IT IS WHAT
I'M HEARING YOU SAY THAT- FOR
THE NEAR TERM DURING THE
PENDENCY OF THE GUIDELINES
IMPLEMENTING THIS LEGISLATION.
THAT IN ORDER TO GET. SOURCES
AND THEN BUT THERE WON'T BE SOME
KIND OF ADVANCED MITIGATION
ACCOUNT AS- SB ONE ORIGINALLY
ENVISIONED WHERE YOU WOULD HAVE
SORT OF- ADVANCE FUNDING PRIOR
TO PROJECT APPROVAL THAT COULD
BE AGGREGATED- AND SAY. YOU KNOW
YIELDS SIGNIFICANT FUNDS EVEN AS
SOON AS THIS FISCAL YEARS THAT
AN UNREASONABLE EXPECTATION
SHOULD WE BE THINKING MORE
ABOUT. THAT ARE YOU GUYS
THINKING MORE ABOUT JUST DOING
THIS THROUGH. EXISTING DOLLARS
AND NOT DEPENDENT ON THIS
PROGRAM TO GET THESE OTHER
PROJECTS GOING- MITIGATION PER
PROJECT OCCURS WHETHER WE'RE
DOING WHAT THE FASCINATION OR
NOT- BUT ADVANCED MITIGATION THE
GREAT OPPORTUNITY TO GET
MITIGATION AHEAD OF PROJECTS
THAT WERE NOT DELAYING OUR
TRANSPORTATION PROJECTS. WE CAN
ALSO AGGREGATE. EDUCATION BUT WE
DON'T HAVE POSTAGE SIZE
MITIGATION WE HAVE LARGER
MITIGATION- BUT TOGETHER SO IT'S
NOT A SMALL MITIGATION THAT'S
WHAT'S AFFECTED- AND THEN IN
TERMS OF THE WILDLIFE CAN%
ACTIVITY THIS IS ONE ASPECT OF
OUR INVESTIGATION IT'S NOT THE
ENTIRE TIRED IN IT THERE'S-
OTHER RESOURCES THAT WE MITIGATE
SUCH AS WETLANDS THAT- SPECIES
THAT DON'T MOVE HIKE UP PLANTS
AND HABITATS THE- RECROSS THE
STATE SO THIS IS ONE COMPONENT
OF IT WE ARE. DEFINITELY MOVING
FORWARD WITH OUR OVERALL ADVANCE
NEGATION PROGRAM WE'VE
IDENTIFIED PROJECTS UP AND DOWN
THE STATE AND WE ARE MOVING
FORWARD WITH THEM BUT THIS
EFFORT RELATED TO WILDLIFE
CONNECTIVITY WILL EXPAND OUR
ABILITY AND ALSO MERRY SOME OF
OUR- ADVANCE NEGATION EFFORTS
WITH THE WILDLIFE CONNECTIVITY
NEED THAT IS OUT THERE- SO THAT
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO GET
TO IS. BEING ABLE TO UTILIZE
SOME OF OUR ADVANCED MEDICATION
ABOUT FUNDING IN A WAY THAT IS-
STILL GOING TO ADVANCE-
TRANSPORTATION PROJECTS AN EX
EXPEDITE THOSE BUT ALSO NEED
SOME OF THE GOALS THAT WE HAVE
RELATED TO WHILE I CONNECTED.
SENATOR FROM MY IT SO JUST THE
PUBLIC DECLARATION MY DOOR
PERSONALLY IS OPEN TO TALK ABOUT
ANY PROJECT IN THE SENSE OF
ADVANCED MITIGATION AS WELL. I
THINK GERMAN KNOWS THAT. IN
TOMORROW- ACTUALLY BE WITH
CALTRANS AND SECRETARY CRAWFORD
AN ASSEMBLY MEMBER. STONE TO
SENATOR LAYERED IN SANTA CRUZ S.
HIGHWAY SEVENTEEN WAS GOING
THROUGH KIND OF MODERNIZATION.
FOUR FIVE YEARS AGO- WE- ROAD
AND AGREE WITH. THAT WAS OUR
FIRST OF PILOT OR HAVE BEEN
AGAIN. AND WE KNOW HAVE A
OUTLINED UNDER CROSSING AT ONE
OF THE SIGNIFICANT CURBS ON
HIGHWAY SEVENTEEN SO IT'S ALL OF
THE ABOVE. YOUR BILL WILL MAKE
IT FASTER AND MORE CLEAR BUT WE
ALSO NEED TO AVAIL OURSELVES OF
ADVANCED PROGRAMS AS WELL. THEY
SAID INSIDE EVAN PRECIADO THE
TESTERS TEST MY VERY EXCITED
ABOUT THE ITEM- THANKS FOR
TAKING EXTRA TIME ON IT- I KNOW
WE HAVE STAFF RECOMMENDATION
APPROVED BUDGETED- BUT I WOULD I
WOULD JUST ASK AS YOU AS YOU
ROLL THIS OUT. KEEPING GAUGING
LOCAL GOVERNMENT. AT OUR
CONSERVANCIES- AND OTHER
ENTITIES TO GET STRATEGIC ABOUT
THIS WORK NOT TO JUST BE
REACTING PROJECT BY PROJECT BUT
TO GET AHEAD OF THIS AN
INTEGRATED INTO YOUR BROADER
REGIONAL BIODIVERSITY PLANNING-
AND TRY TO GET SOME BIG
VISIONARY WORK DONE THIS YEAR I
THINK IT'S A GOOD YEAR TO DO IT-
THIS IS REAL INFRASTRUCTURE.
THESE ARE ALSO UNION JOBS I
SHOULD NOTE THAT AND- AND ANYWAY
I APPRECIATED BOTH. BOTH
DEPARTMENTS WORK. VERY GOOD THAT
CENTER DOLLY. I JUST WOULD LIKE
TO. ASK THE DOCTOR BOTTOM- AND
WE SWITCH SPOKE- LAST YEAR ABOUT
THE ISOLATION QUITE FRANKLY OF
THE MOUNT LINE UP AND IN THE UP
. IN THE SOUTHERN PART OF THE
STATE WHERE THEY CAN'T SO
THEY'RE INTERBREEDING IN THE- SO
ARE YOU GUYS ARE YOU ABLE TO.
BEFORE WE GET THESE CROSSINGS IN
THE ABILITY TO HAVE- YOU KNOW
THE WORK DONE ARE YOU ABLE TO
MITIGATE THROUGH MOVING- IT
DIFFERENT POPULATIONS AROUND TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE THAT THE TO.
GET OVER YEAH SO THAT THEY HAVE
THEY HAVE THE ABILITY TO- I
DON'T KNOW WHAT THE CORRECT
SCIENTIFIC WORD IS BUT BASICALLY
SO THAT THEIR DOORS NOT
INTERPRETING IN THE SAME AREA
FOR A LONG TIME. YES BUT- SO WE
WITH THE PARK SERVICE WHICH YOU
KNOW IS A GOOD PORTION OF THE-
SANTA MONICA'S DOWN THERE WE ARE
ENGAGED IN CERTAIN KIND OF
SCIENTIFIC PILOT PROJECTS IN
THAT SPACE. IN THE BUT PART IS I
MEAN THE LIFE CYCLE OF MOUNT
LENSES WHEN YOU. RELOCATE A
YOUNG MALE YOU OFTEN END UP
PUTTING THAT ANIMAL IN THE
TERRITORY THAT'S ALREADY
OCCUPIED. AND OF COURSE THEY
COMPETE- SO WE'RE DOING SOME OF
THIS FOR MONITORING AND WE'RE
LEARNING. ANSWERED ALL OF THE
OTHER THING I'D ADD IN THE SPACE
IS KIND OF THE YES BUT THE BUT
PART. IT'S NOT ALWAYS THE CASE
THAT THE PLACE YOU'RE RELOCATING
A LARGE PREDATOR WELCOMES US
MOVING A PREDATOR TO THEIR
BACKYARD SO WE'RE WORKING
THROUGH THOSE ISSUES- BUT IT IS
SCIENTIFICALLY PART OF WHAT
WE'RE ENGAGED IN IN THE STATE WE
ALSO SEE THE SAME THING GOING ON
WITH SOME OF THE FISH SPECIES.
WHERE WE'RE GOING TO NEED TO
MOVE THEM INTO HABITAT WHERE
THEY CAN ACCESS COOL CLEAN
WATER- BETTER. THAN AND YOU KNOW
KIND OF WHERE THE TRUCK NOW. X.
EXCELLENT WELL THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION IS TO PROVE HIS
BUDGET AS I SAID ON THE PREVIOUS
ISSUE BEFORE US. PLEASE FOLKS AT
FINANCE PLEASE CHECK YOUR EMAIL.
THURS THE SENATE DEMOCRATIC
BUDGET PROPOSAL CALLS FOR TWENTY
BILLION DOLLARS IN
TRANSPORTATION PROJECTS AT WORD
WORD BEFORE US IN WITHIN THE
EIGHTEEN BILLION DOLLAR CLIMATE
ADAPTATION IS A- BILLION DOLLARS
IN NEW BIO DIVERSITY FUNDS.
DIRECTOR BOTTOM MIGHT BE OF
INTEREST TO YOU AND SOME OF THE
OTHER FOLKS ON THE LINE BUT
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND NOW
WE'LL MOVE ON TO ANYBODY. IN THE
ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED TWO WOULD
LIKE TO COMMENT ON ANY OF THE
ISSUES THAT ARE BEFORE THE
SUBCOMMITTEE TODAY SAYING
ABSOLUTELY NOT A SOUL HERE IN.
M. TWELVE HUNDRED WILL MOVE TO
THE PUBLIC THOSE PROVIDING THOSE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT ON OUR TELECONFERENCE-
LINE THERE IS A REMINDER TODAY'S
PARTICIPATION NUMBER IS.
844-291-6364 AND THE ACCESS CODE
IS ONE FOUR ONE ONE ONE. FOUR
MODERATOR IF YOU'LL PLEASE
PROMPT INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT WE WILL
BEGIN. READ THE COMMISSION IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO LEAVE A
MESSAGE FOR MUSICIANS PRESS ONE
VERIFY WE'LL GO TO LINE EIGHTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. A GOOD
AFTERNOON CARE WHAT MEMBER
STEVEN MYERS SPEAK ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE PARKS
FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT OF THE
INVESTMENT IN ITEM THIRTY TWO
TWENTY WILL THE DEPARTMENT OF
PARKS AND RECREATION TO IDENTIFY
CAPITAL OUTLAY PROJECTS THAT
WILL IMPROVE VISITORS
EXPERIENCES AND REDUCE BARRIERS
TO PARK AT. THE DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITY IN ADDITION ON BEHALF
OF MY POTENTIAL OF REGIONAL OPEN
SPACE DISTRICT AND THE LAND
TRUST OF SANTA CRUZ COUNTY IN
SUPPORT OF THE FUNDING ISSUE
THIRTY CREEK EMPLOYMENT SB SEVEN
NINETY. MISSION THE CALTRANS AT
THE F. W. ARE CRITICAL TO
FACILITATING WILDLIFE CROSSING
PROJECT ALONG AND ACROSS THE
HIGHWAY INFRASTRUCTURE THANK.
YOU SO MUCH. NEXT. I HAVE NO ONE
ELSE YOU HAVE TO COME HIGH THEM
CLOSER. HEARING FOR EVERY IT
BACK TO THE D. S. WE WILL NOW GO
TO OUR- ONLY CAL- DO WE HAVE A
MOTION ON SENATOR I'M ON ISSUES.
THREE THROUGH NINE. ELEVEN
FOURTEEN FIFTEEN SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN AND TWENTY THROUGH
TWENTY NINE SO. THERE'S A MOTION
BY SENATOR DOLLY AGAIN THIS IS
ISSUES THREE THROUGH NINE ELEVEN
FOURTEEN FIFTEEN SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN. AND TWENTY THREE
TWENTY NINE THIS ROY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL I CASKEY BY. BECAUSE HE
HIGH DOLLY. DOLLY I REQUIRE.
REQUIRE HIGH STIRRING ALL RIGHT
STERN AYE. MISS PLEASE SEND DOWN
FOR. THE VOTE IS FOUR ZERO. FOUR
ZERO MATTER SIR PROVE ON ISSUES
NUMBER THIS IS PHOTO CALENDARS
THIS ISSUES ONE INTO TEN TWELVE
AND THIRTEEN SIXTEEN AND
NINETEEN CENTER REQUIRES THEIR
MOTION. IS A MOTION BY SENATE
MCGUIRE MYSTERY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL WHY CASKEY HI MY CASKEY I
DOLLY. REQUIRE MCGUIRE AYE STERN
ALL RIGHT STERN AYE. THREE ZERO
THE VOTERS THREE ZERO THOSE
MATTERS ARE APPROVED UNDER
DISCUSSION CALENDAR ISSUE NUMBER
THIRTY ONE- THIS IS THE- FIRE
MARSHAL HIS THIRD THE REX
SEPARATE CONDITION IS TO REJECT
THE- THE MATTER IS THIRD OF
MOTION. SENATOR REQUIRE MOVES
MISS ROY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
WHY CASKEY HI MY CASKEY I TALLY
. HI DALY I. REQUIRE REQUIRE HI
IS THAT RIGHT. THE BOOK. IT IS
NOW YEAR IS. THIRTY I WOULD
STAYING ON THE- SENATOR ALI IS
MRS MR PLEASE FAKE THE ROLL CALL
BUT WE STILL. TO ROLL CALL IS
VACATED WITHOUT OBJECTIONS IT'S
MOVED NOW LET'S START THE ROLL
CALL AGAIN ON ISSUE NUMBER
THIRTY ONE THIS IS- THE
DEPARTMENT OF FORESTRY AND FIRE
PROTECTION THE OFFICES STATE
FIRE MARSHAL THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION IS TO REJECT
MOTION BY SENATOR MCGUIRE.
PLEASE CALL ROLE. MY CASKEY HI
MY COUNTY AYE DALY. DALY NOT
VOTING REQUIRE REQUIRE AYE STERN
RIGHT STERN AYE THREE ZERO THANK
YOU FOR NOTICING THAT THE ROLE
OF THREE ZEROS TO VOTE MATTERS
APPROVED ON ISSUE NUMBER THIRTY
THREE THIS IS- THE WILDLIFE
CONNECTIVITY ACTION THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION IS APPROVED AS
REQUESTED IS OUR MOTION CENTER
STERN. SO MOVED THERE'S A MOTION
ON ISSUE NUMBER THIRTY THREE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. WHAT KASKY
HI CASKEY I DALY FINALLY AYE
MCGUIRE. GLAD HI. ALL RIGHT
STERN AYE FOUR ZERO PLEASE THE-
VOTE IS FORCED THE MATTERS TO
THANK YOU FOR ALL IN THE WHO FOR
IN THE PUBLIC APPOINTED IF
YOU'RE UNABLE TO SATISFY PLEASE
SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS AND
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
SENATE. THE BUDGET FISCAL REVIEW
COMMITTEE OR VISIT OUR WEBSITE
YOUR COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS
ARE IMPORTANT TO US YOU WANT TO
INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY IN THE
OFFICIAL RECORD THANK YOU FOR
PRECISION EVERYONE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE TODAY NO WE
STARTED. WE WILL CONCLUDE THE
AGENDA FOR TODAY SEE YOU NEXT
TUESDAY AND WEDNESDAY ON VARIOUS
MATTERS WE ARE NOW WHAT YOU'RE.